green day green day geschenkt so jan
schenk der green day the greenery
einfach geschenkt ganze welt für ein
schönes wochenende
münchen meine lieben freunde und
willkommen zu einer folge minecraft
fries zusammen mit sturm würfe na wie
geht ihr mit geht's zum guten witzen
sitzen
wir haben uns gedacht heute für den wenn
die folge bei mir kommt du nimmst du
nicht auf namen
heute ist der 20 und ich muss echt sagen
ich bin ja ihr wisst es mittlerweile ich
war in fast jedem video sage wo bist du
eigentlich gerade dies geheim sein fällt
eben hatten hier ja ich mache ich
vertrage kartoffeln können sie natürlich
gerne mit kunden kommen rein können
wobei nimmerland piraten fähig macht es
wieder zu ihr und wissen ja nahezu alle
dass sie jetzt am vorproduzieren bin und
ich voll nehme diese folge gerade auf wo
ich auf twitter gepostet habe dass wir
heute den ganzen tag in einer therme und
im aqualand waren da war so ein
salzwasser beck und meine augen tun
richtig weh aber es war richtig schön
entspannt waren meine augen sehr
unterschiedliche farben erste workshops
gefallen die haben wirklich zur
unterschiedliche farben
ja aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
wirklich zu unterschiedliche farben sind
oder ob das einfach nur daran liegt
mindestens windows live ich meine nicht
das denkt man aber du musst mal
überlegen dass das linke auge ist auch
umrandet von anderen farben als das
rechte so ein bisschen es gibt auch
diese optische täuschung mit den schwarz
weiß das grau auf einmal so aussieht wie
grau aber es ist eigentlich ein weiß nur
weil es durch den schatten den spanier
aber es ist ja es ist ja nur dort unter
der der
bei mir ist sogar atomwaffe ich bin rom
würfel willkommen meine lieben unis
denn die kirche ist übrigens sehr sehr
hübsch kartoffeln in kosova kopierter
essen das ist tatsächlich realität des
waldes bringt am meisten ehrlich und es
geht recht schnell versionen ja noch nie
gesehen ist das hier und wir kommen
kuchen rein denn weder schimmel noch mal
einen gang mehr fällig und zwar im
märkischen wir sind ein bisschen ruhiger
die letzte folge ist mir erhalten aber
geplatzt im kopf die diagnose macht es
war doch der sturm waffe was meinst was
war das bei mir krisen krebsen kann
sitzen ich krebs krebsen krebsen harry
potter manie von krebs korb oder so
kriegst gibt's schließlich drittens
borkum am eingang hier machen möchte
das ist eigentlich für megaprojekte in
der stadt darmstadt oder käfer ist jetzt
einfach so ein riesenhaus im bau was
ehrlich wer guckt aber das passt ja
garnicht hinweis da dort auch versichern
stadt kehren weil du bist so es muss
jetzt mit einem gang hier ich habe ein
bisschen angst runde zu springen macht
macht machen das ist 1000 mitglieder
lara 1000 liter an
ich mache hier unseren gegnern aus
schnee und dann geht dazu über langsam
insel habe ich jetzt ich hab so das
passende heute
dann geht das so über weiße sofort so
geht das dann so ich mag mir dass ich
mag es mich mal kunstmarkt mit mit
marken von deichmann weil ich das so
einfach so ein bisschen so den gang hier
habe ich mir zugedacht war durch mich
natürlich wieder verbaut
also nie was ich eigentlich sagen wollte
die folge wird ein bisschen ruhiger sein
weil wir halt gedacht haben wir gehen
einfach mal fragen ein da wollen wir
auch jetzt schon direkt anfangen weil
das in den letzten folgen bisschen zu
kurz gekommen ist
was hast du also ich mache mich
attackiert
du kannst deinen weg raus nimmt genau
die planer noch nicht also den anderen
rausnehmen gibt
nein ich habe frank aus
die erste ist von real gab den namen
gehört es über youtube nicht ausgespart
aber nie
und sagte okay die stürmer verlegen sich
wohl grad kann ich mal ab
hallo unter den schirm werfen mal
irgendein problem mit teams kicken sind
jetzt auf anderen ausgewichen
auch es regnet
die russen wieder die lust ist die frage
die frage ob ich nicht mehr mitbekommen
die ich habe nur gehört ja die wurde von
blablabla gestellt meinte das richtig
aussprechen aber ende
ok jetzt gefragt im des momente wo ihr
dachtet vor weihnachten total unnötig
also so als fest
menschen den schlaf habe ich mir glaube
ich noch nie ist der regen effekt kann
sein ja ist glaube ich so effekt ich
meine ja ich weiss nicht kann ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht beantworten ich
weiß nicht ob ich mir schon mal gedacht
habe dass ich lieber obergericht mit
rein sich gerade habe ich mir nie
gedanken darüber gemacht ob das fest
jetzt unnötig ist oder nicht
also ganz ehrlich gesagt dass wir zu
beantworten
also ich habe bin halt voll in dieser
vermehrt schiene drin ich mag meine
offenheit genauen weil die werbung und
die ganze industrie aso gemacht es ist
weil es ja klar
und je mehr ein dortmunder wurde bekamen
die kinder in bangladesch bearbeiten was
auch immer einfach nur das dass dieses
ding also aufgebaute sich inzwischen der
kleinste schön wenn ein
von daher habe ich tatsächlich ein bis
dato habe ich aber nie darüber
nachgedacht besser mit ihm gehabt
es ist mega interessante frage und es
ist krass solche fragen auch ankommen
über die man sich echt wo man sich zu
denken
stimmt können wir mal drüber nachdenken
aber noch nie gemacht so fries auf also
für dich ist weihnachten einfach da
deswegen geil weil es dazu gemacht habe
was es ist ja genau das ist halt so
inzwischen für familien und get together
und sowas steht wissen ja klar meine
hand ist halt einfach zusammen fest
geworden oder saragossa und opfer und
die sind da und platten block und anders
als richtig cool sondern haben so alle
zusammen die man halt sonst nie sieht
und sorgt dass alles ganz frisch
wie also deswegen genau und sehr gute
frage
kauft ihr für eure familie zu
weihnachten immer dieselben geschenke
oder ich mache jetzt mal ohne dass man
die frage in wie jetzt blöd beantwortet
oder so aber eventuell meint er auch so
immer nur so kleinigkeiten oder also
oder immer irgendwelche karten für
verschiedene musicals oder so das kann
man ja auch so sehen aber ich weiß ich
sagte immer zuerst wird sagst du da
natürlich nicht also ich tue mich
generell immer richtig schwer
geschenke für meine familie geht und
dabei auch darauf angewiesen sich die
immer wieder frage halt mitbekommen wenn
darin gesagt dass vater oder frauen
remmel
also es sind schon immer
unterschiedliche sachen also
ich meine es ist halt eher so ein spiel
mit dem feuer wenn man sich da 2000
fenster leben finde ich und dann
irgendwie probiert was eigenständig auf
die beine zu stellen aber irgendwas fest
das haben wir eigentlich nicht
bei uns ist es jetzt auch nicht so als
ich kenne es von anderen von einem
kumpel der schenkt seiner mutter bisher
jedes jahr immer irgend so eine karte
weil er hat richtig gern so rockmusik
hört irgendwie und der also nicht so
nicht zu barbaren waren so richtig so
brav wie weil sie das kasan ist katie
melua noch unternehmer rock aber so ganz
geheizt halt's maul nicht indie rock
aber auch nicht punkrock nicht sein so
was in die richtung wo keine ahnung
jedenfalls schenkt er halt immer so
sachen für irgendwelche konzerte in der
umgebung mal da ne band mal hier einen
green day geschenkt so ja ich schenk dir
green day the greenery einfach geschenkt
das für ein schönes wochenende
harpstedt mit dem aber einfach so mal
ein kalender dann über irgendwie das und
das oder ein buch über die teuersten
gitarren oder so so schenkt er also
immer aber jetzt ist echt zum beispiel
letzte hat meine mutter von mir nur
gutscheine für ihn was bekommen einen
gutschein über ein mal essen gehen mit
mir aber ich bezahle nicht oder so macht
ein guter typ aber vielleicht jährige
hat sich noch kein eigenes einkommen was
los bei dir also groß geworden da schon
wieder anfangen müssen bei youtube steht
da nicht mal fünf hatte ich gerade in in
ein zwei oder drei es bis in ein zwei
oder drei gibt der modus auf games are
da gibt's modus ok kratzbürstig ich
glaube die ganze zeit schon so planlos
freue mich von meinen tajani hat die
ganze zeit im weg rum also eigentlich
immer was anderes
ja okay ich mache weiter das hat
übrigens gerade mit den wolf wolf
schimmel gefragt und ich mach mal weiter
mit dani und lp dani 01 fragt wünscht
ihr euch weiße weihnachten ja also auch
megamäßig bock drauf ich städte sehen an
weihnachten zwar schön raus oder so aber
wenn der schnee liegen würde wäre es
einfach so viel cooler
irgendwie so presse so alles so
geschmückt und andere schnee und so das
passt dann irgendwie wenn ich als
säkular schädigen würde und vor allem
auch damals war es bei mir halt so ich
musste mal mit dem fahrrad zur schule
fahren zuvor ein paar jährchen und dann
hast du dir einfach so gedacht bitte
kein schnee kann sich ein 25 grad sein
aber jetzt mittlerweile ist halt so mit
auto und ganzen der bahnumfahrung muss
halt nicht mehr so viel laufen also ich
hab echt dem bock auf schnee vor allem
weil wir halt auch skifahren gehen oder
der schnee hat auch ins kalkül
hier habe ich meine da wo man gesagt
auch zur not auch auf kunstschnee oder
so aber trotzdem einfach fürs feeling
gibt es viele weit genau aber du bist
auch schnee
ohne müsste ich hasse es sind schon
irgendwie bei meiner familie bin
gefahren der normalerweise nicht weg und
machen erst zu hause was dann war es die
letzten jahre alt immer so dass erst im
januar eine januar als angefangen hat zu
schneiden
ja und einfach weihnachten voll das anti
weihnachtsspiel in gescher dass wir das
tatsächlich noch egal ob du sagst das
ist preis ob sie früher sogar noch egal
aber früher wollte ich unbedingt schnee
also ganz früher was mit tatsächlich
nicht so wichtig weil da irgendwie mehr
weihnachten somit kam aber inzwischen
recht wenn kein weihnachten weihnacht
nicht weiße weihnacht ist dann bin ich
tatsächlich habe ich nicht so viele
dinge heiligabend der intelligenten
verstehe was sein möchte ich auf jeden
fall mit einer meinung ich glaube ich
hänge ich weiß dass ich unten dran bauen
solle katar helfen der innenausstattung
wie mama teppich vor ort ist weiß ich er
wolle genau aber weiß leider nicht wie
bestimmt neben anderen wie ein vogel
costa ich bin sofort da du musst du noch
etwas überlegen hier leben hoch und
machen damit wir gleich wieder raus
kommen also nicht ich mein richtig mein
gang hier werde ich dir zweiten ausgang
ich denke ich erfinde nichts gutes
design gefunden ehrlich ich habe mir
also der übelste anti kag in
innenausstattung anti in neustadt ich
hätte jetzt aber wieder an die kacke
sagte anti antifa kinder kinder genau
das ist ja meine band die so ein zirkus
halligalli aus dem haus und schwind
kommt antike name ist programm oder soll
stellenplan alter ich bin eigentlich
schon fertig würde also ist halt super
simpel gehalten weil man sich ganz schön
ja
gut wäre es wenn ich irgendwelche pläne
ist die folge schon längst vorbei das
recht irgendwie was du mir sagen kannst
du für die nächsten zu erfolgen die
ersten zwei folgen mache ich alleine
anschluss das projekt ich will hier so
eine bank hin machen eine schöne kann
man die rausgucken welches ok danke das
war die folge
mit banken die massen bank vertreten
habe ich deine texte packs andere sachen
also es gibt auch andere treppen die
sind zur spielzeuge mir sonst ohne spaß
hast du die im inventar die breite masse
hätte ich hab die gerade hingesetzt mail
zauberei dürfen wir die ganze zeit hier
bei dir die treppe hier bei dir die
ganze zeit weil ich hab die green
gesetzt als du gerade zu mir hin
gesprungen ist dann ist sie kurz die
sport und dann hatte ich die nicht mehr
weg habe ich einfach akzeptieren die
luft gemacht weil sie wieder da er
guckte dass auf jeden fall ein erfolg
gewesen
keine bewertung schaut euch jetzt auch
beim staffel vorbei wie er sein ganzes
haus hier zusammen gebastelt hat
gegangen und sagen damit verabschiede
ich mich für diese folge diesmal wieder